what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks for stopping by the channel today
and it looks like we could possibly have
our final cast for The Fantastic Four
rumors and reports from insiders have
been going crazy the past few months and
we've heard a lot about different
castings for different characters we've
heard everything down from Jody Comer to
play The Invisible Woman to Margot
Robbie playing The Invisible Woman we've
also heard some rumors about the Human
Torch and some about the thing not as
much as Sue storm or Reed Richards and
it does seem like Adam Driver truly is
locked down to play Mr Fantastic a
choice that some people are kind of on
the fence about but I for one think that
it could actually be really really good
I think Adam Driver has a lot of skill
when it comes to acting I think he's a
very great actor he's got a lot of range
a lot of depth and I know a lot of
people just see him as kylo Ren of
course I see him as kylo Ren as well but
he's done a lot of other really great
projects and I say all this because the
casting that we're about to announce
still has Adam Driver playing Mr
Fantastic I'm pretty sure he is
officially our Mr Fantastic that's what
we've heard and we haven't heard
anything to counter that yet in a couple
of months so that is pretty much all but
confirmed Adam Driver is going to be
playing Mr Fantastic now who is the rest
of the team going to be played by well
today the very credible Insider account
my time to shine hello tweeted four
different pictures of four different
Fantastic Four actors who have been
rumored to be up for the roles with the
hashtag fantasticboard hinting that this
is indeed our official team and yes Adam
Driver is on there now the Human Torch
casting is interesting it's Paul Mezcal
and it is interesting because we did
actually hear that he did meet with
Marvel Studios now this was after all of
the rumors about him playing the Human
Torch came out the rumors and reports
came out that he he could possibly be
the Human Torch are Johnny Storm the
brother of Sue storm The Invisible Woman
and then after all of these reports came
out it was revealed that yes indeed Paul
did meet with Marvel Studios however
what was really interesting is the rumor
going around was that he did meet about
the role but turned it down however the
reason that some people said that he had
turned down this role was because he had
been cast for different roles he's
actually in a lot coming up including
the new Gladiator sequel that they're
making however a lot of what he is about
to be in is coming out in 2023 or is
seemingly going to be going into
production and filming in 2023 and if
that is the case then he can definitely
still play the Human Torch because this
movie is not coming out till 2025 which
means they'll start filming in 2024 and
besides I'd also just like to add this
that if you get an offer to play the
Human Torch of the Fantastic Four in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that is
definitely going to be one of the
biggest offers that you'll ever get in
your entire life that's an insanely huge
offer that's an insanely huge compliment
to even get that offer from Marvel
Studios that's a life-changing role and
don't get me wrong he's had plenty of
great roles and he's been offered and
accepted plenty of great roles that are
coming again like his role in the
upcoming Gladiator sequel but we all
know that a huge role in the MCU has the
ability to just completely change your
life and your career forever look at
Robert Downey Jr he did a complete 180
on his life Marvel took a chance on him
they saw back then what everybody sees
now in him so I mean it would be really
hard to deny Marvel Studios role
although don't get me wrong actors
definitely do it speaking of that we
recently heard that Marvel Studios
actually offer the role of the Invisible
Woman to Emma Stone and she turned it
down apparently Emma Stone wanted more
money than they were willing to give her
at least that's what's been rumored
obviously Marvel Studios doesn't come
out and simply release statements about
why certain actors didn't accept certain
roles when the movie hasn't even come
out yet but it is interesting that they
did offer Emma Stone the role of Sue
storm I don't picture her playing Sue
storm in my head and don't get me wrong
of course you can dye your hair blonde
and look the part but I just don't see
personality wise her interacting with
Adam Driver they're both incredibly
talented actors but I'm not sure how
well they would sing together however
who I can definitely see with Adam
Driver is Margot Robbie who apparently
is indeed going to be playing our Sue
storm AKA The Invisible Woman now this
has been reported on by many different
insiders everybody kind of heard it all
at once over the past couple of months
and everybody pretty much said the same
thing Margot Robbie is one of the top
contenders for Marvel Studios to play
Sue storm now of course there was this
big kind of debate on whether or not she
would accept the role because of course
she plays the iconic Harley Quinn in the
DC Universe so a lot of people were
stating well she's not going to take the
role because she's going to continue to
play Harley Quinn however with the basic
reset of the DC Universe we don't really
know what's going to happen with her
character Harley Quinn although James
Gunn did say that he is of course still
open to work with her and he has
expressed how much that he does really
care about Margot Robbie and the
character and I for one think it's fine
for her to play two different characters
in two different franchises I actually
think that's a testament to how talented
she actually is to play two huge main
characters and two really huge iconic
franchises and I for one think that she
has the perfect look for Sue storm I
think that this is actually an
incredible casting choice and of course
something that is also extremely
important is I think that her and Adam
Driver are going to have really good
chemistry together I think they are both
extremely talented actors and I also do
think that they kind of look pretty
great together as well so as far as the
MCU selling us on and convincing us that
Margo go Robbie Sue storm and Adam
drivers Reed Richards are in love with
each other and they're married and they
have kids I don't think that's a hard
sell at all in fact I think a lot of
people are going to really enjoy
watching the two of them together on
screen but hey let me know your personal
thoughts about this down below and we'll
talk about the team chemistry in just a
bit but of course we have to talk about
the thing and it does look like David
Diggs is going to be Ben Grimm aka the
thing now this was actually the last
casting rumor report that I believe we
talked about the iconic Hamilton actor
up for the role of the thing in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe he is Jewish
and we've heard that Marvel Studios does
want a Jewish actor to play Ben Grimm
since Ben Grimm is Jewish in the comics
so he checks the role for that he is
also an incredibly talented actor and
he's done a lot more than just Hamilton
I recommend checking out blind spotting
or snow piercer the series or The Little
Mermaid he is in the recent Little
Mermaid and of course that is a Disney
film so he's already working with Disney
they already knew they enjoyed working
with him that he is an incredible Talent
so it makes sense that Marvel Studios
would want to grab him for Ben Grim the
thing and again I have to State this
because every time I see comments
talking about somebody's stature and
size for the role of the thing guys
they're just gonna do mocap or they're
going to give him some sort of
prosthetic suit we know this by now Mark
Ruffalo is not the size of the Hulk it's
all mocap at this point however I am
actually a big fan of true prosthetic
suits that look extremely real but we'll
see what they do so as far as we're
concerned right now this is our cast for
The Fantastic Four Adam Driver as Reed
Richards aka Mr Fantastic Margot Robbie
a sue storm AKA The Invisible Woman Paul
muscal as the Human Torch or Johnny
Storm the younger brother of Sue storm
and David Diggs as Ben Grim aka the
thing and I can see this I can see this
casting work for a few reasons one I
already mentioned I think Adam Driver
and Margot Robbie will have great
chemistry together but at the same time
I think Adam Driver and David Diggs will
have great chemistry together as well
which you need they are best friends
they meet in college they hit it off and
their best friends till the end pretty
much their family the Fantastic Four
family I think Margot Robbie will act
extremely well with David Diggs as well
and I know Paul muskel is a really
talented actor but he's the only one
that I am really curious to see how he
meshes with everybody else I'm
definitely convinced that he can play
the younger brother of Margot Robbie and
he definitely has the potential to be
Johnny Storm the Charming and kind of
cocky and arrogant sometimes Human Torch
he'll definitely have some pretty huge
shoes to fill because of course
everybody is going to compare him to
Chris evans's Human Torch sorry that
we're skipping a generation of human
torches there but I think everybody
understands Chris Evans is Human Torch
is the iconic Human Torch that everybody
thinks of when they hear that so I think
this cast as it is right now will
actually be pretty good I I think this
is a pretty decent choice I want to say
it's a great choice but of course we
need to see them all dressed up we need
to see them all interacting with each
other so what I'll say right now is I'm
actually pretty happy with this right
now I'm happy with Adam Driver Margot
Robbie and David Diggs I'm definitely
willing to give Paul mascal a huge
chance I think he's talented enough to
pull this up as well I think the cast is
going to interact with each other well
and have good chemistry but hey let us
know your thoughts about all of this in
the comments down below do you like this
casting choice or not be sure to like
the video and if you subscribe and leave
a comment you are entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
and some DC items as well the winner
gets to pick one item and we pick a
winner at the end of each month only a
few days left in this month so be sure
to subscribe and leave your comments
down below also we are now on patreon
and appreciate any type of support
you're willing to give we also have a
website where we post to daily about
other news we don't talk about on the
channel and a Discord server as well
we'll link those in the comment and the
description down below you can follow us
on Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
me